[Música]
la catedral de Alejandro nevski lleva el
nombre de un santo ruso del siglo XIII
es uno de los muchos símbolos del
patrimonio cultural ruso en la capital
búlgara
Hola Cómo estás Muy bien estos dos
hombres Son miembros del partido ruso
filo búlgaro al que representarán en las
elecciones legislativas del 2 de abril
su programa se basa en la amistad ruso
búlgara la cual se perpetuó en 1878
cuando el zar Alejandro II expulsó a los
otomanos de Bulgaria toda nuestra
historia está irremediablemente ligada a
Rusia no solo a causa de la liberación
de Bulgaria de la esclavitud por parte
de los otomanos
sino también por todas las cosas que
tenemos en común
la fe la espiritualidad el alfabeto
atanas y maxim se unieron a la
manifestación organizada ese día ante el
monumento en honor al ejército soviético
el consejo municipal de Sofía acaba de
decidir trasladarlo a un museo
provocando la ira de los nostálgicos del
bloque soviético
solía jugar aquí de niña en 1959
no es justo que quiten este monumento es
un crimen porque hace parte de la
historia búlgara
Esta es una historia que cada vez divide
más a la población búlgara especialmente
desde la invasión rusa en Ucrania a
inicios de 2022
el monumento fue atacado por
manifestantes que defendían a Ucrania
estos ataques al patrimonio cultural
ruso avivan los sentimientos de
hermandad entre Bulgaria y Rusia
estamos aquí para decirle no al fascismo
Y sí a la amistad y la hermandad con
Rusia
socialistas comunistas o nacionalistas
prorusos del movimiento
Renacimiento son una parte del espectro
político búlgaro que se reúne frente al
ayuntamiento de Sofía cuya fachada
pronto se cubrió de pintura y huevo
entre los manifestantes se recitaba un
discurso común sobre la guerra en curso
que acusaba en particular a los
proccidentales de haber provocado la
inflación actual de cerca del 20%.
después de que Rusia dejara de
suministrar gas a Bulgaria
el coste de la vida aumentado por haber
roto nuestras relaciones con Rusia
queremos una normalización de estas
relaciones
nuestro partido político lucha por una
Bulgaria neutral una Bulgaria que no
esté implicada en la actual conflicto
militar entre Ucrania y Rusia
[Música]
desde el inicio de este conflicto la
presión sobre el partido rousófilo ha
aumentado y su líder Nicolás y malinov y
hasta procesado desde 2019 Por espiar al
servicio de Moscú en junio de 2022 70
diplomáticos de la embajada rusa en
Sofía fueron expulsados por espionaje en
ese momento el gobierno estaba dirigido
por kil petcop un centrista Pro europeo
que entregó indirectamente municiones y
combustible a las tropas de kiev en las
encuestas el apoyo a Putin y el gobierno
ruso ha disminuido del 60% al comienzo
de la guerra a poco más del 20% en la
actualidad los búlgaros se han dado
cuenta de que pueden separar su amor por
la cultura rusa la literatura y la
música rusa por un lado y el régimen de
Putin por otro
este giro en la opinión búlgara se vio
reflejada en barna Ciudad a orillas del
mar Negro donde se manifestó mucha
solidaridad con las decenas de miles de
ucranianos que llegaron al comienzo de
la guerra
cuando llegaron los ucranianos recibimos
muchísimas donaciones no solo de
búlgaros sino también de rusos que viven
en barna
fue reconfortante desde hace décadas
barna es un destino muy popular para los
rusos muchos de ellos se han instalado
aquí como el caso de Víctor batured
Beach que llegó hace 14 años fundó
berezca una cadena de supermercados de
productos rusos conocida en toda
Bulgaria el empresario siempre ha
manifestado su oposición a Vladimir
Putin más aún desde el año pasado
obviamente hay gente que está a favor de
la guerra y otros que ni siquiera
utilizan la palabra guerra
suelen ser personas mayores
no conozco a nadie de 30 o 40 años que
sea proputín
Víctor presta apoyo financiero a las ong
encargadas de ayudar a los refugiados
ucranianos
930.000 de ellos han llegado a Bulgaria
desde febrero de 22 la mayoría continuó
luego su viaje hacia Europa occidental
se cree que unos 50.000 siguen en el
país el reto ahora es que se integren en
la sociedad búlgara en este centro de
acogida social de barnas se hace todo lo
posible para que los niños ucranianos se
sientan a gusto
estamos poniendo en contacto a niños
búlgaros y ucranianos si es interesante
ver lo fácil que es para los niños
comunicarse a través de los juegos
ese día Denise originario de Odessa vino
a participar en las actividades del fin
de semana su madre Larissa que llegó con
él a Bulgaria en marzo de 2022 está
totalmente tranquila por la acogida que
reciben
mi hijo empezó el colegio aquí en
septiembre en segundo de bachillerato
estaba muy estresada por cómo lo
recibirían pero no hubo ningún problema
Esta benevolencia hacia los refugiados
ucranianos va de la mano de una reciente
aversión por la política del presidente
Ruso y los búlgaros ya miembros de la
otan y de la Unión Europea cada vez
miran un poco más al oeste